I feel very strongly everyone should be
free and ideally comfortable to be
themselves
it doesn't mean you should be forced to
broadcast it
[Music]
hey folks
I'm gonna talk in the broad sense about
representation of queer people in Media
I haven't done a broader take on this
topic in a little while that was
actually kind of how I started out
tackling queer topics on this channel at
all and
the thing is there was something that
happened
not even that recently last year
that
I didn't really know what to think about
and
I think I'm ready to talk about now
because
it basically exposed a blind spot in
some of my own thoughts feelings and
positions
not one that made me change any of my
existing views
but led me to adopt a little more Nuance
to them
because
Nuance is important
and nothing is ever always so
um very far away from when it happened
we're going to talk a little bit about
Kit Connor
he is an actor who was appearing in the
series Heart Stopper which no I have not
seen
and he received some criticism
of a perception of queerbaiting because
he was perceived
as being straight when he was playing a
gay character I believe the character is
gay I mean a non-strike character let's
just go with that sorry I haven't seen
the show
and in October of last year
on Twitter
he came out
and said very flat out
I feel forced
because I've been getting harassed and
accused of queerbaiting I am actually
the thing I am portraying
congratulations you force an 18 year old
to come out
and he was right to be angry
because
he shouldn't have had to do that
and I say that as someone who has gone
on record repeatedly a very strongly
feeling that it is important
that queer people play queer roles now I
am admittedly a lot stronger on that
feeling when it comes to trans roles in
particular as opposed to gay or bisexual
roles the reason for that having to do
with the fact that when a cisgender
person plays a trans person not only is
it you know shutting out trans people
being able to take part in their own
stories it also reinforces a lot of the
underlying false biases and bad
information that people have because no
matter how good the performance is when
a cisgender person plays a trans role
somewhere in the back of their head an
audience is going to register all this
as someone who is really the gender they
assigned at Birth but is just pretending
because that's what the actor is doing
so casting cisgender actors especially
ones who whose identity is the gender
that the character they're playing
transitioned out of
so like having a CIS Man play a trans
woman
or a CIS woman play a trans man then you
are literally just putting up someone
who is for all intents and purposes just
going to pretend that they are not the
gender they were assigned at Birth
and it reinforces the idea that we fake
this and we pretend and it's not real
now while that makes me a lot more
um kind of put my foot down about it
when it comes to trans representation
the general principle of
we should be involved in our own stories
I do feel that also holds for other
queer identities be it other
gender-based identities such as
non-binary
um or uh genderqueer or anything of that
nature but also gay lesbian bisexual
pansexual now given how many well not
just sexualities but gender identities
there are trying to get someone who is
the exact thing that can get a little
finicky and a little overly nitpicky for
my tastes but at least getting part of
the queer community
to me feels important especially now
especially these days with everything
going on
I do feel it is important even in a part
like a gay CIS man
to get someone of that Community to play
that part because
as I said shutting queer people out of
our own stories
isn't empowering to us and it doesn't
help us
it ignores us
it tells us we can tell your stories
better than you can go sit to the side
buy ticket when we're done doing this
correctly
and when
queer people get to play leads or get to
play these roles it's pretty much always
in smaller independent
um not big budget things by and large
because
well
we don't have that many big name gay
queer
Etc actors
because they're not allowed to even play
what they are when it is the lead role
but that's sort of the general overall
principle by which I do feel it is
important to get members of the queer
Community play queer queer Parts overall
and I've talked about this repeatedly
over the years
but I do have to admit
it had never occurred to me
that an actor would be forced to come
out
in order to push back against criticism
of them being a non-queer person in a
queer role that legitimately had never
occurred to me
and part of that is is honestly kind of
an outdated mode of what it means to be
closeted and I'm not even sure that's
the right word in this a particular
scenario but what I mean is
in my mind
if someone was in the closet my
conception of in the closet meaning you
know I'm not ready to admit it to
themselves not ready for the world to
know and you know just all bottled up
and still coming to terms with things
they wouldn't take the part of a queer
character
like that that's just going to confront
them with something they're hiding from
what didn't occur to me
is that there are some people especially
celebrities especially young celebrities
and professional actors
who just want privacy because it's none
of your business
and they're right
because that's the thing kit Connor
wasn't claiming to be straight
what he was doing was not answering
questions about his sexuality because
well it was Nobody's Business
and that's something we're actually
seeing again currently
with Doctor Who and shurigatwa
I've seen it noted on multiple places by
some commentators I've even seen it in
some write-ups like news write-ups
commenting that he's
the first queer person to play the
doctor the thing is
we don't know that
and I know some people are going to give
me side eye on that and call me weird
and naive because well you can look at
how he has chosen to appear in public at
things like Greg Carpet Events and go
come on but the thing is
shirigatwa has never answered questions
about his sexuality and he shouldn't
have to
we don't know if he's gay
bisexual pansexual
non-binary we don't we don't know
anything about those things
because he hasn't answered question
about because he doesn't have to if he
doesn't want to
now he's also not claiming to be
straight
if he ever did say he was I will admit I
would be a little surprised but
he's not out as gay
he's not out as queer he's not out as
anything
because his sexuality
if he even has it because heck the man
could be asexual for all we know
but whatever it is
n't our business
and that was the line that kit Connor
was trying to walk
it wasn't anybody's business
and the thing was he wasn't hassled at
casting
the problem became when there were there
was a photograph of him holding hands
with a co-star of his For an upcoming
movie the movie's called the Cuban
Girl's Guide to tea and tomorrow and the
actress is rafiko and there was an image
of them holding hands
and once that came out
he started getting harassed for
queerbaiting the idea that he was trying
to lean into this community or build a
career off of this community that he was
not a part of
he felt it necessary to come out
and it wasn't a happy experience for him
so what do we do
because this was wrong
this should not have happened
but
I do still believe
very firmly
that queer people should be telling
queer stories at least at this point in
time because I'll reiterate something
that I've also said before people will
go well that's not fair because like I
you know actors should be able to play
anything or would you be okay with a
trans actor playing a CIS character I'm
like yeah I would well that's not fair
no it's not
newsflash life isn't fair the thing is
right now
there is a phrase that I'm very keen on
emphasizing
all things being equal
actors whether they are queer or
straight
should be able to play whatever role
they are best suited for
however that phrase all things being
equal matters because right now things
are not equal
in terms of the ease with which these
actors are cast even as themselves much
less is something that they are not
and the number of roles that are even
open to them
the nature of the representation it's
not equal
and if we ever get to a point where we
are on more even footing
sure
fine
but we're not there yet
and acting as if we are already on equal
footing when we're not just locks in the
inequities
but
this still is an issue and one that I as
I said had not thought of
and I am not someone whose prayer who is
prepared to go well it's just an
acceptable casualty it's a it's the cost
of moving in the right direction I don't
accept that
I don't accept that for a couple reasons
first is
he felt the need to come out
because he was getting harassed now
granted this was on Twitter and it's
difficult to know
because of the nature of well internet
anonymity but the nature of Twitter in
particular it is difficult to know what
percentage of the people harassing him
were genuinely upset for the reasons
they stated how many of them actually
even watched Heart Stopper
and how many of them were just jumping
on an issue that they that maybe
mattered to them sincerely but like they
didn't have ever anything that where
they knew all the details I mean
obviously they didn't they didn't know
all kinds of stuff but like how sincere
these people's anger was it's hard to
know it can get performative real quick
but
I shouldn't have to say this but I will
harassment is wrong
it's wrong
it's why even when I talk about people
who I do not like
I will point out do not harass them do
not threaten them
my honest thing is that you should not
be engaging with these people at all
talk about them if you must do not
engage with them directly leave them
alone
we'll talk about these things as they
come up and it's necessary but don't
harass people ever
it doesn't matter to whom the cruelty is
directed The cruelty itself is wrong
that is also Doctor Who that is a sixth
doctor quote from a big Finnish story
called holy Terror it's amazing and is
my favorite Doctor Who quote and I will
keep coming back to it
so that's the first thing harassment not
okay not okay
but
setting that aside and realizing that we
can't
just give up trying to do something that
I at least think is important to try and
do that getting queer people into queer
roles
because of a handful of harassers who
just need to stop
they need to stop
so
what do we do
if we take it as granted harassment is
wrong
but we still need to avoid this
situation in the future where people
feel the need to come out whether it is
because of direct harassment or just
general cultural pressure because of
the kind of situation that honestly
people like me are trying to make where
straight people don't get cast in queer
roles
at least not right now
but how do we handle that
well with nuance
and on a case-by-case basis
because I'd say the first thing to take
into account
with anyone is age
I would say
generally as a rule of thumb not I am
absolute rule but as a rule of thumb
if they're under 20
maybe we shouldn't even be asking this
question about what their sexuality is
because I mean honestly it's not our
business no matter what their age is but
especially when they're at the age when
a lot of us are either are or would have
been trying to figure it out in the
first dang place
no
but does that mean if they are over 20
that we go hey hey we need to know are
you queer person who's playing this
queer out well well no a point to
shooting Godspell again granted the
doctor isn't explicitly queer although
the doctor is hinted in more than a few
ways of being kind of queer but despite
that not being an intrinsic part of the
character he's playing like that's still
none of our business you don't get to
hassle somebody at a certain age just
don't do it so how do we then address
that
Here's my thought going forward and this
is a position that requires a little leg
work if we're gonna call somebody out
first of all again without harassing it
should be those
who have publicly stated
their straightness
and cisgender identity
who are taking on these roles
if someone just has never said
they've never said it's not confirmed
you cannot find anything where they've
ever claimed to be straight
leave alone
the thing is the number of actors who
actually do that
who legitimately do not
engage even at a surface level with
those questions
at all
there aren't that many
now there may be more in the future
depending on how younger generations of
performers choose to handle the media
but at least at the time that I'm
talking and understand this is never an
absolute statement nothing is ever
always but like I'm open to amending
this in the future but at my time of
talking
I would say that the number of actors
who are maintaining
basically no answer to their sexuality
and or gender identity they're just not
addressing it just going no I'm not I'm
not talking about that
leave alone
that is an uncommon enough occurrence
that I'm prepared to give the benefit of
the doubt
because
my
personal issue
is not with someone who is super private
whose identity we don't know playing a
queer part
that's not what I'm worried about that's
not what frustrates me
what frustrates me is someone who is
known to be cisgender and or straight
playing a queer role
that's what bothers me
I don't need to get worked up about
somebody who we just don't know like
well we don't know okay then I don't
have the information with which to be
bothered
don't make a leap just so that you can
get angry
get angry based off what you know
get angry of what you can substantiate
and even when you get angry do not
harass people
when you don't know
just accept that you don't know
and until you do
you don't have a basis by which to call
out that particular actor in that
particular case
people can get
about this
and like try to weed out every instance
because if I'm being honest even if kit
Connor was straight
this wouldn't bother me nearly on the
scale of something like when Scarlett
Johansson was cast to play trans man now
again yes that's a trans issue versus a
just a gay or a lesbian issue and I've
explained why that's a bigger problem
for me but like
somebody of that
stature
coming in
and claiming a role a lead role
that could have gone to an up-and-coming
queer person that just won't now
that's where my biggest frustration is
when we're dealing with young people
when we're dealing with unknown actors
especially when we're dealing with
actors who we don't know
I'm not going to say there's no issue at
all but it's not where the focus needs
to be that's not where the problem is
or at least to my mind not the big part
of the problem that's not even secondary
that's not even tertiary that's way down
the priority list
so
to my mind the best way to avoid this in
future is to accept when you just don't
know
and don't fly off the handle
based off an assumption
which of course won't actually work as a
practical matter because
you know people are going to do their
own thing and they don't always listen
but that is how I am going to operate
moving forward
and I hope other people will consider it
as a potential template of course I'm
open to suggestions on a better way to
move forward
because as I said
this is a blind spot for me and I'm sure
I've got others
I'm not perfect
I've got learning to do too
what do you think about all this
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
enables me to do this as by living and
Tackle topics that I want to talk about
and not worry too too much about the
algorithm but even if you can't help me
out there like share subscribe are also
big help and there's links to other
things I do in the description that you
can check out as well there's even merch
including Pride merch and things like
that but don't uh don't worry too much
about it
what I really want you to remember
is that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
massive thanks to my patreon supporters
and in particular I want to thank Robin
Moore Zubin look full up to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime Ruth
Oliver B solitary pictures
Ulrich Bogdan Melinda Walters Jen the
oatha Boyd Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
for Nabi likes the poodle Robin Powell
Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam RDL
Taylor David Hall Shayla gourlay and
Rosalind Bennett thanks for your support
you can get your name in the credits too
if you feel like hearing me possibly
struggle with it for several times
before getting it right
[Music]
I don't know